- [Voiceover] Let's compare 5/6 and 5/8.
Let's think about what they mean.
5/6 means five out of six pieces.
If you have a whole,
let's say a whole cake
and you cut it into six pieces,
5/6 is five of those six pieces.
5/8 again is five pieces.
That's something that's the same.
We're both talking about five pieces,
but this time, we've split our cake
into eight pieces, so it's
five out of eight pieces.
We can represent that by drawing it.
Maybe we can draw, here is one whole.
And then another one.
So these are two equal wholes,
and on one of them, we can shade 5/6
and the other 5/8.
That way we can look and compare them.
So for 5/6, if we divide this whole,
and we were using the example of cake,
into six equal-size pieces,
not sure if those are perfect,
but let's say those are
six equal-size pieces,
5/6 is talking about five of those pieces.
So one, two, three,
four, five.
This image represents 5/6.
Now for 5/8, let's think
about it for a second.
Will the pieces in 5/8 be bigger
or smaller than 5/6?
Are eighths bigger or smaller than sixths?
Well, we can draw and see.
If we have the same size whole,
which we need to have the same size whole,
and we draw and we split it
into eight pieces this time,
so now we have fourths, and eighths,
these pieces, these eighths,
1/8 is smaller than a sixth
'cause this time we had to split the cake
between eight people, so
we got smaller pieces.
Now again we can shade five of them.
Seems like five pieces might be equal
to five pieces, but we can look and see.
Four, five, and now we can look and see
the 5/6 takes up more
space, takes up more area,
this is a larger amount,
and the reason is because
each sixth, each piece is larger.
So five larger pieces is more
than five smaller pieces,
or is greater than, and
remember with our symbol,
the open side, the larger side,
should be facing our larger number.
So 5/6 is greater than 5/8.
Here's one more, but this time,
let's try to compare them without drawing,
let's just think about what these mean.
2/5 means two pieces out of five.
So one whole was split five ways
and we got two of the pieces.
2/3 means that same whole
was split three ways
and we got two of the pieces.
Well which two pieces are larger?
The 2/3 are larger, 'cause if we only
have to split our pieces three ways,
we can have larger pieces.
So the 2/5 are smaller.
These two smaller pieces are less...
These two smaller pieces are less
than the two larger pieces, and again,
the open end of our
symbol should be facing
the larger number.
So 2/5 is less than 2/3.